hey guys it's Justine and I'm so excited
because today I'm going to be unboxing
for you the brand new MacBook Pro 15
inch and the Blackmagic Design EGP you
first things first
let's unbox the MacBook Pro then we'll
get to this guy and if you do get this
be very careful because the handle is
not a functioning handle at all I've
already learned the hard way so this is
be completely expect out 15-inch MacBook
Pro and you guys might be like Justine
you're absolutely crazy
and I'm not gonna deny that fact at all
my entire job revolves around making
videos so the faster that I can make
those videos the more videos that I can
make or I could just hire an editor but
I actually really enjoy editing so Apple
announced two new refreshes to the
MacBook Pro with touch bar there's 15
inch and a 13 inch so the top of the
line 15 inch MacBook Pro is a 6 core I 9
a 4.8 egga hertz 32 gigabytes of ram and
a 4 terabyte solid-state drive the
top-of-the-line 13-inch is a 4 core 2.7
gigahertz i7 eight gigs of ram and you
can get up to a 2 terabyte solid-state
drive so this really is a huge upgrade
from the previous versions I mean
basically the MacBook Pro that I have
right now is a completely spectat one
from late 2016
so this one is pretty much double what I
have previously I at most of my videos
on the go I would say probably I mean
it's over 50% of the videos I edit when
I'm traveling and before I got the 18
core I'm a pro I edited 100% of my
videos on a laptop
it really is hard when I'm traveling
going back to editing on the laptop but
will the introduction of this laptop
with 32 gigs of ram and a 6 core
processor and the 4 terabyte solid-state
drive which is an extremely expensive
Edition when I say extremely expensive
like you could buy an entirely other
computer for the amount that you would
pay for the 4 terabyte solid-state drive
so if you are looking to save money that
is one easy place to save on I mean I
think it was like $3,200 extra for the 4
terabyte drive I know well let's open it
up this is purely an unboxing video
because it's actually pretty late right
now it is oh it's 10 p.m. way past my
bedtime and in a later video I will give
you guys a comparison between this and
my previous MacBook
it's completely unnecessary to cut the
Box open like this I'm well aware one of
the things that was hoping is they would
make the computer look a little bit
different sort of like when they
launched the new Apple watch they put a
little red dot on it not that I was
looking for a red dot or anything my
sister also ordered one and she was
debating on whether to go with the
silver as opposed to the space for a
spoiler alert she got the space gray as
well it just looks too good not to let's
do this it's always so exciting every
single time there's not much of a smell
okay there we go oh yeah that's what I
was looking for I'm shook this looks so
clean you guys wouldn't you see the
comparison of my laptop and compared to
this one it looks like it's been through
an actual war oh it's already turning on
I was ready
also in the box we've got USB see we've
got some paperwork and of course the
power charging brick now not only do the
new MacBooks get a spec jump but they
also got a new display these now have a
true tone display which means as the
light shifts and changes your screen
will also change color so it'll become
warmer or cooler depending upon the
light situation now for me I do a lot of
video stuff a lot of graphics a lot of
color work I'm probably not gonna have
that turned on because the last thing
that I want is my colors to shift as I'm
working on a project I do have it turned
off my phone - I'm not a huge fan of it
but I feel like depending upon the type
of work that you do on your computer
it's something that can be super helpful
so these MacBook Pros also have the t2
chip which first debuted me iMac pros
and that will allow for a secure boot
encrypted storage and also let's not
forget Siri oh shoot no
oh no no no no you got to be very
careful when you say the HU y si RI in
my household if you guys are looking to
upgrade and you are looking to save
money I think the biggest thing that you
can do is not upgrade it to the four
terabyte drive I would recommend getting
the two terabyte if you are doing a lot
of heavy data stuff because my sister
did get the one terabyte and she said
that she is running out of space so many
times when she's editing videos but I do
most of my editing actually off of these
drives these are the Samsung these are
the t3 versions I also have the t5 which
is a little bit faster than these
because I do travel a lot and I'm
editing from my laptop to my iMac pro
all of my current projects that I'm
working on I edit from here I also like
to have a backup off-site just in case I
happen to lose one of these and as I say
that I know that there are some things
on here that they don't have backed up
so I should probably put these down
there something bad happens another
thing that is new is this keyboard it's
not entirely redesigned I'm not really
sure what they did to make it quieter
but it is much quieter okay so now let's
do a sound test of the two keyboards
this is my old Mac this is the new Mac
I'm going to type Justine was here over
and over again
it's definitely quieter feels like
slightly springier and just like a
little bit softer I'm not sure if it's
the sound that's throwing me off let's
try again I'm also a pretty aggressive
type or so when I type I'm pushing very
hard on the keys I'm the worst person to
room with in a hotel ever so
aesthetically these computers look
almost identical except this one is
dirty and scratched so now it's time for
this
this isn't a GPU if you've never seen
one of these before it's ok I don't
really get it I've been very well aware
of these because I have been wanting to
try them out for a really long time
especially because I do a lot of stuff
on my laptop basically what this is is
it's an external graphics processing
unit so what that means is you can get
the quality of a desktop computer in a
laptop so this essentially is just a
graphic card that helps accelerate the
graphics inside of your laptop it says
that this can speed up the graphics on
the new 15-inch MacBook at two point
eight times so I will be testing this
out in a future video but this is just
an unboxing and a little setup of the
MacBook so stay tuned for that ok so
here it is so what makes this different
than a lot of other GPUs I've been
checking out the razor one and I was
thinking of getting it just to review
and test it out this is sort of Apple's
answer to a well it's not even that
complex but for most people who just
want plug-and-play
that's what this is most other GPUs are
upgradable this one is not you can add
multiple cards whereas this is just it's
a very Apple solution you plug it in and
it should work so this has four USB
ports two Thunderbolt and also an HDMI
out this is one of the first a GPUs to
support a thunderbolt display so that's
pretty awesome you can also charge your
macbook through here basically if you
want the power of the desktop in your
laptop this is the way to go
this is $699
so the do have an eye Pro this probably
isn't something that I'll be using that
often when I am at home this is
something that you would be getting if
your laptop was your primary computer
whereas this actually you can use it for
the iMac Pro so that'll be interesting
to see if that makes any difference this
is really big it's super aggressive I
mean I guess it looks cool it is a very
consumer friendly way to turn this Mac
into a processing power Beast a lot of
other EGP use are massive they're loud
so I'm gonna be interested to see what
this thing sounds like I know a lot of
you guys are probably super hardcore PC
people and you're probably laughing at
this but to that I say not everyone is
like you you will say but these Gray's
watch pretty well this has four USB
ports and two thunderbolts and an HDMI
you can connect various accessories here
with the USB ports you've ever done any
sort of VR stuff on your Mac or if you
have an HTC vive I've used that before
when I'm editing 360 content so that
will allow you to see the 360 stuff that
you're editing in actual 360 when you're
moving around I'm very excited to try
this out I've always been fascinated by
these and I have not ever had a chance
to check them out so now I have a really
good reason to try this out and one of
the razor ones which I have been eyeing
up for quite a while ever since they
announced support for e GPU so I was
like mmm that's something I want to get
into it well thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
video this just was a quick little
unboxing I'm gonna start shooting and
working on my review video I kinda will
be doing a comparison between just sort
of my everyday workflow of editing
videos between this macbook my other
back book and my imac pro so just to
give you guys a little comparison and a
speed test to see how much time I will
save if you guys are new to my channel
make sure you guys hit subscribe and hit
the bell so you'll be notified when I
post a new video I have a lot of fun
stuff coming up so I don't want you to
miss it be sure to leave me some
comments as well because I will be
scrolling through there and replying to
you guys I would love to know what you
guys think of the new GPU and the new
MacBooks well see you guys in my next
video bye time to edit Oh
oh I'm gonna edit this on minut no I'm
and it doesn't my macro because the I
micro is still faster than this and I
don't have anything downloaded yet
so that's tomorrow's task
[Music]